[Music]
hey guys Hallie here and so is St
Patrick's Day now I know we all want to
be festive and whip up some green treats
to celebrate but if you're like me
sometimes it's hard to find the time but
don't worry keep calm and leprechaun as
et's resident lifestyle expert I've got
your back with a super simple super fast
super easy way delish treat that'll have
you your friends and family feeling
ready to Shamrock and roll get it
Shamrock rock and roll anyway green mint
shakes not only are these drinks totally
cute they're yummy and dairy free too to
get started let's make the frosting to
coat your glass you'll need 3 4 cup
butter alternative at room temperature
one and a half teaspoons vanilla extract
one tablespoon oat milk and three cups
powdered sugar I'm using Planet oat oat
milk because it's Rich creamy and
delicious trust me it's so good you'll
want to lick the frosting right off the
spoon
using a stand mixer or a hand mixer with
the butter until it's nice and fluffy
add in the vanilla and one tablespoon of
oat milk
then mix in the powdered sugar one cup
at a time at a low speed until the
frosting is good and smooth next spread
the frosting along the rim of your glass
and coat with your choice of decorative
sprinkles now that your glasses are
ready to go it's time to make those
shakes you'll need four cups Planet oat
vanilla non-dairy frozen dessert one and
a half cups Planet oat oat milk 10 drops
of green food coloring add a half
teaspoon mint extract and to garnish
you'll need dairy-free whipped cream
rainbow candies chocolate gold coins and
gold sprinkles this part couldn't be
easier throw those ingredients for the
shake into your blender Press Start and
let it do its thing pour the shake into
your frosting and sprinkle lined glasses
top with a little whipped cream candy
and sprinkles and Savor the smooth
creamy taste of planetos okay let's all
get in a green mint this shake will be
the life of the Patty
[Music]